What's, like, the common factor out of all of us here?
Gamers.
Yeah, but, like, what else?
What else do we all have in common?
Money.
But everybody has money.
Money, in, like, some way or form.
Right.
So, like, that's not really a good comparison, because that's, like, comparing us to chat.
Because we all have money.
But what makes us different from chat?
We're all, like, living, breathing.
Yeah, but chat's living and breathing.
Chat's living and breathing.
Yeah.
No, they're not.
Chat isn't real.
Oh, shit, you're right.
Me and my zero viewers.
What the...
Okay, but, like, what else?
Like, don't you have something that we also have?
No.
Don't you...
Don't you remember you have a...
We have different things.
What do you mean, don't you have that, you know, that particularly animate, like, thing in your folders?
I don't think so.
Don't you mean a...
I'm getting gassed right now.
Don't you mean, like, you know...
You know, did you have, like, a...
VTuber model that you're sure for that you streamed, like, oh, really, can you chat, like, pull up, like, clips of you using that VTuber model?
Unfortunately, it's not Tuesday, so...
Oh, so, so you do have a VTuber model.
No, VTubers aren't real, so...
Then what's the Tuesday thing?
Yeah.
So, it's not Tuesday.
Yeah, but what is the Tuesday thing?
If VTubers aren't real?
I don't know.
What is it?
What...
Can you please elaborate?
What happens when Tuesday stays on Tuesday?
So, if I ask you again on Tuesday, will you tell me what...
Would you say what it is?
No, I'd say, fuck you, bitch.
Oh, so, anyway, I'm live now, as well.
Are you live, as well, Surefour?
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
So, hello, everybody.
Welcome to the Party Animals Twitch Rivals team.
We went straight into it with no introduction whatsoever.
Yippee!
Just like how we do our Twitch Rivals.
Anyway, this is my team.
Ditto, Surefour, and Brie.
Um...
I honestly thought that, like, some of them had Party Animals experience.
As in, like, a lot of Party Animals experience.
And that's why I recruited.
I have 7.3 hours.
Did you do several tournaments?
You did, like, two Twitch Rivals tournaments.
No, not Twitch Rivals.
But you did two, like, Party Animals tournaments.
How much did you guys do?
I don't understand.
What did you guys do?
Team threw.
Oh.
It's teams fought.
So what's your placement?
I don't remember.
All I remember is the Murder Crumpets team had a mute that, like, played the game 24-7.
And then, like...
What the fuck?
They soloed the team.
They soloed...
They, like, destroyed...
So they destroyed...
You got destroyed by a mute?
I didn't get destroyed.
You got...
But you said destroyed the team.
Yeah, it's a team game.
Yeah, but it's...
So you're part of the team.
So you got destroyed.
Yeah, I lost.
With the team.
Yeah, so you got destroyed.
So you're not a God of War.
You're not a God gamer.
Well, you know, there's percentages of, like, effort in the team.
And what's your percentage?
I'm, like, 90.
You're, like...
Oh, you were 90% of the team.
Yeah.
So the mute destroyed 90% of the team.
Okay.
Yeah.
But if you're 90% of the team and the mute destroyed your team, you got destroyed by the mute.
Okay, listen.
I was, like, 60% of the team.
I was, like, 80% in the PAL World team.
I was, like, 60 to 80 in the PAL World team, too.
I don't want to be hearing this.
What do you mean?
In PAL World, we all did an equal contribution to the team.
I quote, Surefour, you have to carry us.
You're the carry.
Yeah, and you died to a fucking bug.
I can't...
That can't be controlled.
All I'm saying is if you didn't die to that bug, we could have got third place.
Yeah, well, maybe if you made me more Poke Balls.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we made you a collection of Poke Balls.
What do you mean?
I needed more of a collection.
You did not need a...
It was not the PAL Balls that was the issue here.
It was.
I had to clutch out with, like, minimum PAL Balls.
That'd be great.
Oh, my God.
He was Glorp -ing my shit, bro.
What?
He was Glorp-ing his shit.
Oh, okay, yeah.
I just...
I just wanted to make sure I heard correctly.
Thank you.
Okay, yeah.
You know Glorp?
Glorpnorphin?
No.
Yeah, Glorp.
It's a little cat.
It's a little green cat with antennas.
Oh, you're talking about the cast thinking about that SpongeBob rapper?
No, I'm talking about Glorp.
Glorp?
What the fuck is Glorp?
There's Glorp.
And there's Glorp.
Oh, my God.
Wait, he's so cute.
Yeah, he's Glorp-ing.
Oh.
Yeah, he's Glorp.
But that makes sense.
Yeah.
There's Y'Lorp.
And there's Orlorp.
Basically, there's a color for every Orp.
There's a color for every Orp?
Wait, what are the Orps?
Well, there's like Blorp, and that's blue.
And then what?
Orp?
I have to look.
You have to look?
You don't know them by heart?
All I know is the...
No, I only have Glorp.
Glorp, let's go.
It looks like a Neopet.
I love him.
Glorp.
Cat.
Basically, the beginning letter is the color.
And Glorp is Glorp because it's green.
Is there Yorp?
Yorp?
There might be...
There's no Yorp.
There's no yellow.
There's no yellow cat.
There's Blorp.
Is there Blorp?
There is a yellow one.
No, there isn't.
There's Blorp.
I don't see any.
Is there...
I think this is a myth.
I think only Glorp.
No.
It's real.
I think this is a myth.
I only see Glorp.
There's no proof.
You only see what you want to see.
And then where's the...
Where the fuck is Yorp?
Where's Yorp?
I'm looking for him.
Yeah, you can't find him.
No, I can.
Where's Yorp?
Yeah, he's gaslighting.
No, I'm not.
Yeah, I found...
Here's Yalorp.
Where is it?
Posted in a Team 3 chat.
My Team 3 team...
There we go.
Wait, there is Yorp.
Oh my God.
Wait, how did you find Yorp?
My chat helped me.
Oh, so you didn't do any of the work.
I got helpers.
So you didn't do any of the work.
No, it's a...
You ever heard of a community?
It's a community effort.
Wait, I thought chat wasn't real.
Then how are they helping you if chat isn't real?
You know, like schizophrenics where they have voices in their head?
What's that?
So the voices in your head helped you.
Oh, we're getting pinged for stuff now.
Okay, nice.
What?
Who are we?
All right.
It's time to find the lobby.
Please be careful.
Does this hide the code when we join it?
Okay, okay.
I have no idea.
I'm gonna fucking hide my game screen first.
I don't know.
Oh, I joined a random game.
Okay, custom game.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Custom game.
And then you search it up.
Okay.
Search.
What time is it over there for you, Ditto?
Ditto, what time is it?
It's 4 a.m.
Oh, no.
She's locked in.
I can find it, Bobby.
Maybe it's not up yet.
Oh, no.
It's up.
I'm in it.
Oh, I can see it.
I got it.
I would join JoyGaden.
Yeah, yeah.
Join me.
I'm in.
Also, it does show up.
It does show the code.
Oh, Doki.
You're on an online.
Oh, I'll invite you in.
Let me see.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where are you?
Oh, wait.
Give me a sec.
Let me see if I can invite you.
Oh, my friend.
Oh, I need to add you in this.
Oh, wait.
No.
I got you.
Okay.
I sent you in.
Did you get it?
Are you Pussy Slayer?
Yeah.
Is that Pussy Slayer?
He's Pussy Slayer, by the way.
Oh, my God.
He's here to slay some cats.
I'm not thinking I'd be in Twitch Rivals.
It's okay.
We're so locked in.
I was watching Drops Team fucking scrimming.
They were scrimming party animals for like two weeks.
Two to three weeks.
Why didn't you set up a party animal?
Yeah.
I set up scrims.
Why did I not set up scrims?
Would you actually join scrims?
Yeah, you're a team leader.
If I set it up, would you though, Surefour?
Yeah, I'll take that as a fucking no.
I'm always down for scrims.
Yeah, I don't think you would fucking scrim party animals.
Yeah, I was watching fucking Drops with the full on apes.
Apex roster screaming at party animals and hard-comming.
It was actually crazy.
Apex players are sweats.
Wait, what's the comparison between...
What about Apex versus Overwatch?
Who's sweatier?
Apex?
I think Overwatch tries to be sweatier, but it just comes across more depressing.
Oh shit, is that true?
No one talks in Overwatch anymore.
As an Overwatch player, are you sweaty?
Yeah.
We've gone through enough one-tricks that never swap.
We've become complacent with everything.
That's so true!
I was the one-trick.
So, you know...
You were the problem.
I was in Mercy main.
And I was in D.Va main.
You were part of the problem.
You were 100%.
I avoided you.
I avoided you and reported you.
Oh no.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Do you know what the game mode is?
It's Lollipop Factory.
Lollipop... yeah.
Yeah, it's the one where you...
You collect the cheese.
Yeah, and then you have to move it to a little tray.
And then you have to pull the lever to put the tray in.
And then there's a big gummy bear that's worth way more.
Yeah, I'm just gonna be beating the shit out of them.
Okay, so what's the strat for this?
I remember when I tried to play this and I got absolutely destroyed.
You have people trying to stop them from putting in candy.
And then you have people on your team putting in the candy.
And I'm gonna be interference.
Okay.
I'm just gonna be beating the shit.
I'll help bring candy over.
You gotta protect me.
And I will bring candy over.
I don't know what Bree is gonna do.
I will beat people up.
Okay.
Are you good at beating people up?
Yes.
Okay, okay.
And you're not lying to me like how you lied earlier, right?
I would never.
I will protect you.
I'm indiscriminate in my beating.
Alright.
Wait, no, you're not supposed to beat us up.
You're part of the team.
If I have an AOE weapon and you guys are caught in the crossfire, there's nothing I can do about it.
Then we lose!
I thought you wanna win!
Hey, listen.
If I have the lollipop stick...
This is party animals.
This is serious.
There's AOE.
I'm serious.
But you're a gamer.
That's why I'm saying...
That's why I'm forewarning at the beginning.
But you're a gamer.
You should be able to, like, control the beatings.
No, listen.
I can't control the actions of my teammates.
I can only control myself.
Yorp is just on my screen.
Oh, I'm ready.
Yeah, he's just yorping.
Alright, here we go.
I believe in us.
We're so ready.
No, we got this.
Oh yeah, we're gonna win.
Alright.
Where am I?
Okay, here I am.
We have to go grab the candy.
The candy!
Let's go!
Beat him up, Trevor!
Beat him up, Bri!
I got a taser.
Oh, they're going for the big one!
Oh my god.
I'm trying to pull... get the little ones.
Somebody beat up the big ones while I grab the little ones!
I'm grabbing it.
Wait, where's the...
I'm punishing them.
I'm going.
Guys, I actually don't remember where the...
Where the...
The what?
Where is our area?
Oh, there it is.
We're red.
Take the candy.
Okay, I'm grabbing the mini candies.
Don't worry, guys.
I got it.
Nice.
No!
Wait,
we got the big one?
Wait, we got the big one?
Nice.
Am I... Oh, I can't pull it!
Guys, help!
I can't pull it!
Somebody help me!
He's fucking punching me!
I need somebody to help me pull it!
I got it!
Big?
I've been punching the shit out of them over here.
Just keep getting the big one and we win.
I had trouble fucking...
Okay, I need somebody to help me.
I need help!
Yes!
Wait, I don't think...
You have to go the long way.
You can't do it from there.
Up the ramp!
Guys, help me!
Liam's trying to beat me up!
Liam's got me!
I'm grabbing the small one.
You guys go do your thing.
You guys don't tip me.
I'm slowly heading over.
Oh, he's got the pants.
Oh no!
Liam!
Get off of me!
They're getting the big one!
We need to stop!
Okay, somebody fell in there.
I don't know who that was.
That's me.
Guys, we need help.
They're about to get the big one.
I hope you guys are doing it.
If you can just keep getting the small ones, it's fine.
We got him trapped under here.
No, don't please!
I'm just a little dog!
I'm grabbing the small ones.
Please!
Run, run, Ditto!
He's on me!
We're holding hands!
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm just going!
Oh, you stole the big one?
Nice, nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
I got three of them down right here.
You can steal it.
It's okay.
Just keep grabbing.
He's too busy on me.
Oh, take it, take it, take it.
I got him.
I got him unlocked.
It's okay.
I'll go put this on here.
I'm coming.
I'm coming if someone can get the lever.
If someone can get the lever.
I got the big one.
Oh my god.
We win.
Wait.
Yeah.
Guys, I used the cooldown.
I used the cooldown.
I used the cooldown for a small one.
I didn't realize.
Pull the trigger.
A trick.
I can't do well in a penalty game.
We did it.
Yippee.
See the line on my resume, Maya.
Okay, sure.
How much did Bri actually help?
They clutched out by stealing.
They clutched out stealing it while I was just fucking perma knocking three of them on the ground.
Guys.
Wait, is it?
Do we do it again?
I don't know.
I thought it was only one.
Best of three?
Best of three.
Is it again?
Do we have to go through it again?
No, it's game two is buzz ball.
Oh, I know buzz ball.
What is buzz ball?
Do we do it?
What?
That's the one where...
I don't know.
Let's just play until something happens.
Yeah, let's just play it.
Yeah, they're going for it.
They're going for it.
Oh!
I'm going.
I'm dragging it.
No!
I'm going for the little ones.
Fuck this.
You guys can deal with that.
I know my place.
Punch him.
Nice.
You got him.
Oh, game is ending.
We won the game.
Yay!
Okay, I'm pretty sure buzz ball is the one where there's a ball and you have to throw it in the goal and if you hold it too long it explodes.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah.
It's like soccer.
Okay, I get it.
Yay!
I got a cow!
Got the avatar.
I'm glad we're unlocking characters that we get from playing the game once.
It's okay.
You know what?
After that first game, you know what?
I believe in us.
I didn't believe in us before we started, but now I believe in us.
It's hot.
If you get into that little thing at the end and you just press right click, it usually gets thrown in.
Okay.
Boom.
I'm using controller, so let's right click on the controller.
I don't know.
I use keyboard and mouse.
Whatever you throw is...
If two people hold onto the ball, it explodes.
Oh, okay.
So we shouldn't hold... okay.
We can.
Sometimes it's clutch.
You gotta right click it!
Yay!
You just locked up and just locked?
What the hell just happened?
I did it!
So that's the throw button.
That's easy as!
No!
Oh god!
Alright, go, go, go!
Okay, I know two!
You got it!
Someone punched me out.
It wasn't me, I swear.
I know.
It was an enemy.
The bats got it!
Nice steal, nice steal!
I got knocked out.
Get it out.
Just hold on to it.
That's fine, that's fine.
No, it's not fine!
It's not fine!
It was in the end not fine.
We got the bad RNG.
I was hoping it would go to their side.
Alright, here we go.
This time we got it.
I believe in us, team.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that's you.
Nice throw.
Come on, go Pussy Slayer, go!
No, Pussy Slayer!
I got knocked out.
I got knocked out too!
No!
I got knocked out!
Okay, guys.
Now I don't have confidence anymore.
Hey, we're only down one.
Do the thing you did last time.
Okay, I'll just run and grab it.
It's sixth, it's sixth.
I'm trying to grab him.
I grabbed him instead!
You got it, you got it!
Oh my god, it won't let me!
Okay, I'm just running again.
I'm running, no!
No, please, please have mercy!
No!
No, you knocked me out before I could get there!
I got knocked out!
Wait, winnable?
No!
Knocked out again!
It's up to you, Pussy Slayer!
Go, go, go, go, go!
Nice.
Nice pass.
Oh, I knocked him out.
Get it, get it.
Throw it in.
Nice!
Yay!
Now we're tied.
We did it, we're doing it, guys!
We're doing it!
See?
Winnable.
It is, oh my god, it is winnable!
Who would've thought?
I got knocked out.
Why?
Okay.
It's fine.
Get over here!
Okay.
You're holding onto me!
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh, nice throw!
Yeah, but he's heading over.
It's fine, we got it near their goal.
No, he punched it away!
It's not near our goal anymore!
I'll wait for you, I'll wait for the throw.
I'll wait for the throw.
Oh god, oh god.
I'm knocked out.
Oh, big knockout!
We'll throw it if you need to.
You got it!
Go, go, go!
We got it, we got it, we got it!
Yes!
Yay!
Only three more to go.
Oh my god.
It's gone, it's gone.
Yeah.
Pussy slayer with the goal.
Pussy slayer goal!
Got it.
Wait a minute.
Oh!
You're juke- Oh!
Yes!
Let's go!
I don't need practice, look at us!
Just do that every single time.
Just run it down mid every single time.
Just run it down!
I knew Tyler Warner was right in some ways.
My philosophy, run it down.
Okay, never mind, I'm out.
Oh no, oh no, oh no!
It's fine, he fucked up, he fucked up.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Oh no, oh no!
He didn't fuck up!
You liar!
It's okay, this will make the comeback better.
It's fine.
Instead of punching him, I just need to grab him.
Because the punch was missing.
Yeah, that's not good.
I grabbed someone and I dragged him away.
Okay.
Run it down mid.
Run it down mid and then I'll fucking do this.
No, no, I'm out, I'm out!
No!
I'm out, he got me.
I'm out forever.
I'm missing!
No, I'm missing everything!
Oh, he fucked up, he fucked up.
I'm not out?
Oh no, he didn't fuck up yet!
Okay, I'm waiting, I'm waiting, I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
Oh, I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
I'm right here waiting for you.
Nice, nice, nice!
Nice!
Oh my god, is this the next Messi right there?
No, no, no!
Goal!
Those moves!
Alright, this is the last one.
You got this, you got this.
I couldn't think you would do it for me!
Oh god, oh no.
Oh no.
I'm waiting for you guys.
Knock the fuck out.
Oh, oh, she needs help, do you need help?
Oh, I got it, I got it!
Good, good, good.
I got it, I got it!
Oh, they're fucking...
They're harassing me!
We won!
Oh my god, three people can't stop me!
That was four people.
Oh shit, you're right.
Who needs to scrim?
We're just naturally talented.
Oh shit.
I'm out.
I can't even, oh wait!
No, let me in the photo, I'm a winner!
I'm a winner!
Yay!
Is that automatically a win for us?
We don't have to play the third round, right?
Yeah, we won.
What a speed run.
Alright, round two is luggage, chaos, soccer, and winter is coming.
What's luggage chaos?
Luggage chaos is the same thing as the candy one, only you have to put the luggage on conveyor belts, and then they slowly go into a separate area.
That luggage, like, you can't drag the luggage into that area, you have to, like, parkour into it, and then you grab the luggage off the conveyor belts.
And then you put it in, like, the candy, and you just dump it down with the lever.
Oh, okay, so it's just the lever stuff again.
Yeah, it's just, like, slightly confusing.
Like, you can't just walk it to the dumping place, you have to put it on the conveyor belt, and then it goes through, like, a little machine, and then you grab it after.
I see, I see.
Okay, so, like, it's the same thing.
You two are the punching people, and Ditto and I will just put luggage on the conveyor belt.
Sweet.
We're doing it!
I can't believe I'm actually contributing this time.
Oh my god, this is so different from my last Twitch Rivals.
Did you not do well?
I was not contributing.
I did not know what I was doing.
I still don't know what I'm doing, but, like, we're winning, so that's all that matters.
No, you're winning, though.
Just constantly say that you do.
It's fine.
Is this Connor?
As in Connor...
His dance.
Yeah, Connor.
Oh my god!
Yes, suck it!
I'm gonna beat you in the Tekken Geek Tournament 2.
Unless he's on my team.
Still do it!
Still win!
Suck it!
You're gonna lose to me in Tekken 8 as well.
What is this conversation that you're having?
They were asking about their favorite swear words.
Chib asked me about my favorite swear word, and I said, whoa.
Oh, whoa.
What was it?
I thought it was bitch, right?
Your name is in the prologue.
It's appropriate.
I slayed cats.
It's a game about slaying animals.
It's just our team.
You're LARPing.
He likes Glorp.
Oh my god, he loves Glorp, too!
I play Destiny, too.
How do you chat?
Oh, you enter.
Just press enter.
What do you mean, no I don't?
I play Destiny, too!
I don't.
If the streams are deleted, doesn't mean it never existed.
Did you stream it on Tuesdays?
I'm pretty sure that's a special day.
Oh yeah, that's a special Tuesday.
Every Tuesday.
Sunday is the only sacred day.
Why is Sunday a sacred day?
Because I don't play Overwatch.
That's a variety day.
Wait, I thought Tuesday is a variety day.
What the fuck is Tuesday?
That's Wednesday.
Wednesday and Sunday.
Wait, then what's Tuesday?
We don't talk about it.
What's Tuesday?
Then is it Overwatch?
Do you stream Overwatch with your Vtuber?
No.
Then what the fuck is Tuesday?
Tuesday was whatever I want it be.
It's whatever I wanted it to be.
Valid, valid, valid.
I'm valid.
You're valid.
That's right, you are.
Okay, we finished it so fast.
That we have to wait for the other games to be done.
We're just that good.
We're so good at this game.
Until we face the Apex team that's in this.
Wait, which team is that?
I don't know.
That is team...
It's Rogue's team.
Team 6.
That's the Apex team.
No, I think we can go against them.
I mean, these are basically training rounds, you know?
Yeah, but it's gonna determine our seeding.
Oh.
Yeah.
So, it's like the seeded matches.
Oh my god, seeds.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Ditto, are you awake, Ditto?
Yeah.
He's not dead inside.
Ditto's just chillin'.
He's vibing at 4 in the morning.
I haven't slept yet.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I was so excited.
We're playing Honkai Stars.
Yeah, I just finished the main story.
Oh, shit.
I was like, they had a concert and stuff too.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah.
It took me like 10 hours to finish the main story.
10 hours?
Yeah, yesterday.
Yeah, 10 hours.
Wait, how long have you been playing Honkai?
Um...
Yesterday?
Did you start yesterday?
No.
Maybe one month?
One month ago.
So it took like one month of like 5 plus hours of...
I started playing this game on the first day and I stopped playing it and I just came back.
Oh my god.
How much money did you spend?
Um...
We don't count it.
It doesn't matter how much you spend the money on this game.
It doesn't matter?
Yeah.
If it doesn't matter, then you would tell me how much you spend, right?
It doesn't matter if you have fun or not.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Yeah.
So if it doesn't matter how much you spend, then you should be open to telling me how much you spend.
I can't remember.
You can't remember?
Okay.
No, I agree.
I think you should actually celebrate finishing it.
Wait, wait, wait.
How many characters do you have on Honkai?
It's not that much because I just came back.
Maybe...
Let me shake.
Let me open up Honkai real quick.
Wait, how many characters does Honkai even have?
I have 37 characters.
Wait, out of how many?
Are you missing any characters?
Out of 37.
Out of 37?
Wait, how do you know?
I don't know anything about Honkai Star Rail.
Wait, do you even gotcha?
All I know is a lot of people...
I only play gotcha games with PvP.
Yeah, like what?
Well, the last one I played was AFK Arena.
AFK Arena?
Isn't that like a fucking YouTube ad sponsor game?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I see it everywhere.
I see it all on TikTok.
I played that shit like seven years ago.
Wait, is that old?
It's existed for that long?
It's 2018, holy shit.
I haven't played a gotcha game in a while.
The last gotcha game I played was like Genshin because I was like hella bored.
How do you think about Genshin?
Did you like it or did you stop because it was boring?
Yeah.
They made Gonsai.
Gonyu.
So they got that going for me.
That's fair.
They got Gonyu.
Listen, gotcha games...
I only play gotcha games for PvP because like the whole point of gotcha games is supposed to be like buying Gucci wallets but for like weebs.
Yeah.
PvP roster.
I'm surprised you haven't tried out Nikkei.
Why the fuck would I play Nikkei?
Because it's FPS.
If I wanted to look at anime girl ass I would look at something else.
Like what?
Like what then?
Yeah?
Yeah.
What do you say?
I think that's self-explanatory.
You know what that is?
That's a pintai.
I can't
play no gotcha game for that.
That's not cool.
Alright chat.
Rate his taste.
Is it...
Do you have any recommendations?
Now there's some good ones but I'm not going to say them out loud.
That's TOS.
Oh yeah.
Pushing Slayer.
Pushing Slayer isn't TOS.
Yeah but you say it out loud on Twitch instead of writing it down.
Is it...
really bannable?
Yeah.
Well pay for your gotcha games for that.
They're similar.
Why would I pay for it when it's free on the internet?
That's true.
It's for the experience.
Hell no.
I want it to be a competition okay?
You can make it competitive.
It's like...
It's competitive.
Chat can find a way.
Your chat can find a way.
Not my chat.
My chat is say-so.
Christian friendly.
Oh okay.
Mine is full of intellectuals.
Are you dying?
You okay?
I'm sorry.
After hearing you say your chat is filled with intellectuals I couldn't take you seriously anymore.
What the hell is that supposed to mean?
What the hell is
that supposed to mean?
Wait.
We have to ignore the bracket.
A mistake was made reporting a match.
Oh wait.
What's going on?
I don't even know what the bracket is.
Whose bracket is it?
I mean they can't really make a mistake with ours.
Cause we just did something.
Ours was so clear cut.
Yeah.
You said your chat is like say-so.
Isn't that the whole thing like not...
Is say-so like not lewd?
Yeah.
Hey listen.
Anyone that says say-so It's like the Christianity of VTubing.
They're like closeted freaks.
Woah!
What is that supposed to mean?
It's like Christian girls, you know?
They're like freaks.
Woah!
They promised their bodies to God.
Yeah.
And then they threw that away once they got a taste of the forbidden fruit.
Feels like you're speaking from experience.
Experience?
Oh my god.
When is our fucking...
When is our next bracket gonna start?
We did too good.
We won too quickly.
We're just too good.
Next time I'll try to play worse.
No, no, no.
We gotta be faster next time.
I get it.
Next time we gotta be even faster.
We watched you walk into their goal in the first five seconds.
I don't think we can be faster.
They just couldn't register.
They couldn't register what I did there.
Oh, I like the fact that we have Pussy Slayer on the team so that as we do better and better, we just have to constantly pay attention to the first Pussy Slayer as they talk about it.
I thrive on that.
Good.
I got AFK kicked from the lobby.
Yeah.
I almost got AFK kicked as well.
I'm gonna use this time in a runescape actually.
Wait, what are you grinding for?
I'm getting my Warp Scepter right now so then I can clear barrows more efficiently.
Wait, what skill is that?
Well, Warp Scepter is for magic and then barrows is for barrows gear.
So you're trying to get better gear right now?
Yeah.
I'm getting mid gear for my Iron Man.
Oh, you're Iron Man-ing!
Oh.
That makes sense.
Oh my god.
He's multitasking just like a true Overwatch player while waiting in queue.
He's EXP maxing.
I forgot about how long it takes in between matches.
Yeah, that's why you have to start saying like, start making jokes or something.
Oh yeah, help you with your commentary.
Yeah.
Help entertain your chat.
Brie, entertain my chat for me.
My chat's like sludge.
Yeah, be funny for my chat, Brie.
This is your purpose now.
What?
What was the pirate's favorite letter?
R.
No, it's the C's, stupid!
You just call me stupid?
What the?
If you think you're so smart, what's 25 plus 25?
Uh, 72.
That's not...
What?
It's not 72.
I said so confidently.
Why is it 72?
I don't know!
Where did the 72 come from?
Everything's falling apart.
Everything, oh no.
Our momentum is gone!
We lost our momentum!
No!
You were kicked!
Wait, we got kicked out.
That means they're making the room, right?
No, you got AFK kicked, maybe.
No, no, they removed us.
No, I didn't!
They did!
Yeah, they moved us.
We're fighting... Wait, the action just kicked?
We're fighting Kendomerth now.
What did?
Yeah!
Finally!
Get off RuneScape!
Aw, yippee!
Get off RuneScape right now!
I'm getting to my tortoises and then I'll get off.
I'm almost there.
Let's see...
Typing in the Twitch Rivals and then Twitch Rivals.
The Twitch Rivals.
It's not showing up.
It showed up for me.
I spelled it wrong.
I just copied and pasted.
That's actually good.
I don't know why I'm typing them manually.
Ditto.
Okay.
I wonder if they won their last one.
Guys, did the Kendomerth team win their last round?
Stream snipe for me right now.
But like...
But not like unethically.
Unethically?
Ethically stream snipe to just tell me if they won their last game.
They did!
Wait, they did!
They're gamers!
They won their last match.
So they might be gamers.
Where the fuck is Pussyslayer?
Oh yeah, he's still walking over.
Pussyslayer alive.
The last man there.
Yeah, stream snipe respectfully, guys.
Alright.
Kendomerth.
They're here to...
Did you guys win your last match?
Oh, they did.
They did?
I know, I just wanted them to...
I just wanted them to respond.
I know they did, so I want to see if they lied to me.
Oh no, I asked them immediately.
Okay.
We did it.
We're bad.
It's okay, we're making...
We're gonna make them think that we're really bad so they go easy on us.
That's a good idea.
Yeah, yeah.
We got too old.
Okay, we got it.
We have to make them underestimate us.
Make them pity us so that we can do better.
Pussyslayer was a...
was a huge...
It's okay, we can do this, guys.
We can do this.
What the fuck is this?
That's the...
I haven't played this one before.
Put the luggage on the conveyor belt in the middle and then it goes under those little...
like a little platform.
Yeah, you guys have to beat them out.
And then you have to bring it into the room.
Yeah.
You and Tia are gonna beat them up as usual.
I'm just gonna beat the shit out of them.
Yeah.
They can go and take things from the conveyor belt in both the hub area and then our separate little area where we score points.
We gotta just keep it on.
Okay.
We'll figure this out, right?
We're gonna figure this out.
Yeah, I believe in you guys.
I'm just gonna punch shit.
Thank you.
That works, honestly.
Wait, there's a golden case.
Yeah, it's worth a lot.
Somebody grab the golden case.
Oh!
No, he got it!
Wait, he just ran into the thing.
I'm going into their spawn.
Are we red?
Okay, I'm going to red.
I'm going to red.
Guys, they're all pulling me!
I can't even bring the luggage over!
They're pulling me!
I'm out.
Guys, they're really good.
The gold briefcase is stuck.
I'm stuck under it.
Wait, no!
We lost Mandon!
I can't roll!
How do I get over?
Guys, how do I...
Wait, it's actually just stuck.
How do I get over this?
Oh, thank you!
Guys, how do I...
How do we get over...
Guys, I don't...
You can't get over if you have a suitcase in your hand.
Oh!
Wait, then...
You have to put it on the conveyor belt.
Oh!
Guys, I think they're winning.
Yeah, they are.
No, I'm spawn camping them.
We're good.
They were so confused about this game mode.
Okay.
I need help.
They're harassing me.
They're picking me up.
I can't get off.
This isn't going well.
Wait, we have too many people on their side.
You're taking it away from them!
You're taking it away from the goal!
Wait, I am.
Put it here and then put it under there.
I figured it out.
It's fine.
We can catch up.
I don't know if they're harassing me right now.
It's fine.
Guys, they are putting a lot...
I'm here.
They are putting a lot on my end.
I figured out how to do this, but these guys are actually dead.
Okay, if you just hold it...
I can't.
I'm dead.
No!
They have a goal!
They actually know what to do.
No, you grabbed me!
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I grabbed the keys though.
Okay.
Go to the lever.
It's fine.
I'm just doing it.
Please,
we're so near.
I said come closer to us.
Why are they beating me?
This isn't going well.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
That was a bad hit.
Oh my god.
This is so hard.
They are so good.
I'm getting one man harassed.
They took my hat.
Guys, this might be...
This might be a team.
That might win this.
Oh, take it.
Take it.
I fucked them up.
Oh, help.
Yeah.
I got them.
I dropped it.
We're good.
Oh, shit.
What?
It knocked me out.
Wait.
There's a taser gun on my end.
Oh, no.
Guys, this might be a GG go next.
Yeah.
Okay.
No.
We got to get a strat down.
It's fine.
This is trial.
This is definitely not our game.
Okay.
The next one.
Guys, they definitely know we're bad now.
It's okay.
The next one is the soccer game.
Oh, shit.
We can do that.
Okay.
So, I'll beat up the goalie.
That's my job.
Okay.
I'll just beat up the goalie.
And you guys do the other stuff.
That's just not our mode.
All the other stuff.
Yeah.
This wasn't it.
Guys, this is not the Apex pro team that scrimmed every day.
Well, these guys have scrimmed.
They know what they're doing.
They have plans.
Maybe the Apex team was scrimming this team, honestly.
Round two.
Fight.
Wait, are we playing a round two?
No, I think we're just... I think we're just waiting.
Yeah, the owner has only the game.
Instructions were definitely unclear for that game.
We can win this one, though.
Oh, they're Minecraft?
That makes so much more sense.
They're what?
They're so coordinated.
Minecraft players are the god gamers of minigames.
They're just...
Oh my gosh.
I remember when I did Twitch Rivals in Fortnite and a Minecraft player won like top five or something.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
In the Fortnite fucking tournament.
This one I think we have to headbutt more.
How do we headbutt?
Or like we can headbutt?
I don't know.
Middle mouse button.
Okay, what is middle mouse?
I don't know.
Instructions unclear.
Guys, that's okay.
We can lose like one round.
One matchup.
It's fine.
No, we can't lose.
Otherwise, it'll seem like we're cheating.
We just did the, you know...
It'll make the story better.
That's true.
Oh, we're already going.
Oh, this is not good.
Oh, wait, wait.
Two of them are knocked out, though.
Two of them are already knocked out.
I'm gonna go...
I'm going over to beat up the goalie.
Oh, no.
I got it out.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I'm beating up... The goalie and I are distracted.
Guys, I'm distracting the goalie.
We can't hit each other.
Okay.
I got ball in midfield.
Guys, I got the goalie out.
I got the goalie out.
The goalie's out.
The goal.
The goalie's back in.
We're trying to get the ball in mid.
Guys, I'm distracting the goalie.
That's good.
This goalie is so out now.
We're doing our part.
I'm doing my part.
Get out.
Oh, no.
I hit the top rim.
The goalie was gone.
Listen, this ball is hard to control sometimes.
Oh, my God.
That was a good hit, too.
I'm really bad at Rocket League.
This is not...
Guys, this is literally a 3v3.
To be fair, this is a 3v3.
The goalie and I, we're toughening it out right now.
Get out, goalie.
We're fine.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
The goalie and I are having our own slamdown.
Oh, my God.
The goalie's out.
I didn't have enough stamina.
I got the goalie away.
He took away my...
I'm out.
I'm dead.
This ball is hard to control.
They're, like, all rolling and stuff.
You have to go faster.
Yeah, you have to practice.
I keep forgetting.
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm out.
Why ball?
I'm out, but don't worry.
I'm gonna get that goalie out, too.
That's fucking right.
You thought you could have it.
Chill.
That's fucking right.
How the do you roll in this game?
I don't know what it is for a controller.
Oh, I figured it out.
Oh, he knocked me out.
But that's okay.
I thought he can have it.
Good.
That's fucking right.
Get distracted by me.
No!
What the?
I won my game.
Guys, I think if they score the next one, it's over.
What's going on?
Holy shit!
What the fuck am I watching?
Toki.
Maybe we need another one.
Maybe we need another player.
I did it.
I can't believe it.
There you go.
I did it.
Toki spent the entire game just finding someone in the corner and then instantly won.
It's just that easy.
What can I say?
It's actually that fucking easy.
That's fucking right, Rabbit.
You thought I was done with you?
The goalie is distracted again.
The goalie is...
You think I was done with you?
I'm dead.
I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
I'm the striker.
The little bear guy here or the corgi.
He's the one that sets up the combo.
It's fine.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I don't know.
I'm going to fucking beat up this guy, though.
Oh, no.
No!
I'm rolling as well.
I'm doing their strat.
Okay, I'm waiting for you guys.
No!
Okay.
Oh, no.
I'm waiting for the fucking pass.
You walked in with your body.
Thank you.
No!
Oh, my God.
That's so close.
Okay.
I hit it down.
I hit it down mid.
I'm coming over.
I lost my hat.
No, I lost my hat.
No, my hat's blocking me.
My hat actually blocked me.
The one time.
The one time I didn't distract the goalie.
It's okay.
The one time I knew I should never left my post.
You thought you could get away from me.
Okay.
Okay, she did got away from me.
It's fucking right.
The goalie's gone.
Quick.
We need to get the ball over there.
Yes,
nice.
Okay, nice.
The goalie's there, Doki.
I feel like I have to play defense.
I'm scared.
The goalie's going back up.
I didn't want you guys to go there while I distract the goalie.
The problem is I need to play defense.
I can't play D and offense at the same time.
That's what midfield is.
Midfield is D and offense.
That's the name for midfield.
If I go...
If I go full offense...
Alright, I'm going on the offense.
Okay.
What the?
It's back.
Oh my god.
You go offense.
I'll do mid.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I ran out of stamina.
Jumping and kicking into it is very good.
Okay.
Wait, I thought you were fucking offense.
What happened?
I'm just trying to do what I think will be the best right now.
Look at that.
Look at that edge.
Yeah, but there's no offense.
There's no offense.
I'm scared.
If I'm not over there, the ball is going to go into the goal.
Oh, big pass.
There's no offense.
This is your job.
Yeah, well, unfortunately, I pass in mid.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm going in.
I'm going out.
Look at that.
Stalker works and the ball is passing.
I thought you were offense.
Fucking offense.
I can't solo Ronaldo this.
I thought you were Messi.
What happened?
Oh, yeah.
What is this?
I have three on me.
We have a minute.
I'm trying.
I got it.
Oh my god.
All I'm saying is I would have scored.
Nice block.
Bullshit.
No.
We definitely lose.
I did score though.
I gave us our one point.
Hey, I set up that score.
I set up that score.
Oh, you did a good job.
Thank you.
I jump kicked into it at the start.
It's just so sad.
It's just wasn't for us.
This was not our round.
We were against Minecraft players.
If this was banjo ball, they would have been shit on.
What?
What the fuck is banjo ball?
It's a Warcraft 3 custom game.
You should set up a Warcraft 3 Twitch Rivals and then invite them back.
I've been saying that.
Wait, why can't you do it?
I'm not a set up guy.
You're not a set up guy?
Basically, I'm like a side character, main character.
Oh, okay.
But Twitch Rivals is like really easy though to set up.
Because Twitch does most of the work.
Nah.
Then I would have to message someone.
That's out of my pay grade.
They come to you.
I'd rather play RuneScape.
Has there ever been a RuneScape Rivals?
They've had like Deadman modes and shit.
What's Deadman mode?
It's like basically where you play RuneScape normally but you have insane XP rates and if you die once you're out of the tournament.
It's basically like a giant battle royale.
But the entire RuneScape map.
Wait, were you part of it?
Hell no.
I thought you loved RuneScape.
I'm not that autistic.
But you are on the spectrum though because I remember you took the test.
Hell no.
Yes you did.
You took the test.
Listen, every time I've gone to the psychologist they've said I'm normal.
But you took the test.
Are you saying that an internet test is better?
It was a really good internet test though.
It was like a couple of pages long.
They were trying to make me take the test and I was like I'm scared of knowing what I am.
I feel like being great.
It said I might be.
Oh.
Wait, do you remember the number?
There's a different...
In one Discord I'm in we make sure everyone takes the test and then we put the number beside their name of the test.
That's really funny.
What's the number?
I was a 28 but if I answer the question like I'm able to imagine things, I was a 6.
What does that mean?
I can't imagine things.
I was an amputation.
Yeah, amputation.
I was a 169.
I think it's a different test.
I don't think it went that high.
Higher is more autism.
More flavor.
More flavor?
Yeah.
Just a more... I guess like a more more delicious type.
That's... yeah.
Autism is tasty.
Yummy.
Apparently there's one more game they have to wait to finish.
And then...
That we weren't the slowest?
That was like the world's longest match.
That was the longest soccer match ever.
It wasn't that long.
Actually, to be fair, we did lose really quickly.
And then the last one was just long.
Okay, the luggage one was... yeah.
That was a disaster.
The luggage one was...
I accidentally took some of our briefcases to the end.
I was confused!
The instructions were so unclear!
Clear!
You'll get it next time.
It's okay.
If they put that in that...
If they put another round of that in there...
It'll be easy.
We'll know what we do.
We have a system.
We'll be...
We're gonna be so ready for the next round.
I'm almost ready.
What is the third game?
The third round is team score into the game?
What's into the game?
Oh, is that the arcade?
No, we're doing... we're doing Winter is Coming.
No, that's the...
That's round two.
Oh.
Are we still on round...
Oh, wait, no.
We're on round three.
We lost two.
Into the game.
Am I allowed to Google it?
That's the arcade one.
Yeah, the arcade.
Oh my god!
That's dedicated and going into the game.
I can do that.
We can also... I found out that if you take their arcade machine, you can go to the bombs yourself and make them lose scores.
Oh!
Yeah, but I feel like that's a waste because then you're just gonna get punched out.
That's true.
Or do you still get the shield when you go into this?
Yeah, you get the shield though.
So it's worth the risk to make them lose points.
Yeah, and you're wasting time.
Yeah.
If you knock them out, you go to...
Oh, Team Doki, feel free to leave the lobby.
Oh, they want us to leave, okay.
Why do we have to leave?
Because we're the freaking losers.
We're the losers.
We have to leave.
For every winner, there is a loser.
I thought we were gonna win!
Um...
I thought...
Oh my gosh.
You know like, when they did the year of the Luigi, Nintendo ended up losing so much money for that.
So they never give Luigi anything ever again.
Really?
Yeah.
It was like their worst financial year.
Ever.
That's the damn problem with these corpos.
They just look at the finances, and not the lives for other characters.
Their goddamn shareholders and stockholders got them by the britches.
It's not about the money!
Luigi didn't deserve this!
I got my love scepter!
Oh yeah!
High five Rush!
That was so sad.
The company closed down.
I'll remember you always.
How the hell do I charge this thing?
Charge what?
My Warp Scepter that I got.
No!
Yeah.
I'm XP maxing right now.
Wait, that's true.
I should go do my dailies.
Wait, not on RuneScape, but...
Yeah.
Are you doing your dailies?
Did you do your Honkai...
Honkai dailies?
Yeah.
I'm doing it right now.
You're doing it right now?
See?
We're all XP maxing right now.
Am I the only one just relaxing, just chilling?
I have the ability to multitask, so...
That's a lie.
Multitasking is a real...
I'm literally doing it right now.
I'm talking, I'm streaming, I'm RuneScaping.
You're like using less of your...
I'm looking at Twitter.
I'm alt-tabbing.
Yeah, but then you're putting like 20% of effort on each of it.
So you're not putting 100% effort.
Yeah, but RuneScape is very AFK-able.
Yeah, but then you're doing all these other stuff too at once.
So you're splitting your mind.
You're splitting your mind?
You're splitting your mind.
So it's not like actual min-maxing.
You're min...
You're min-minning.
No, I'm max-minning.
Oh, we got it.
Okay, wait.
Oh yeah, the lobby's up by the way.
Did this team win their last game?
Did Job Bartolozzi won their last game, chat?
Wait, Job was a baller?
That's the TikToker.
He's a TikToker?
Who's he?
He's a TikToker.
Wait, what does...
What TikTok does he do?
He screams.
He screams?
Wait, how many followers does he have?
A lot.
Yeah, I think a lot.
Is he an actual real guy?
Oh my god.
He is a real guy.
Holy shit, he has 24 million followers?
What the fuck does he do?
Oh my god, what is TikTok like?
He screams.
Yeah, that's it.
That's good to know.
Alright, I'm gonna watch this.
I'm actually curious.
What is this TikTok like?
Oh, he's a reactor!
Yeah, he screams.
That's it?
That's how he reacts?
Wait, where's my 24 million followers?
I scream all the time.
We won 2-0.
No, we lost.
We lost.
Oh, that's very bad.
Bunny, you lost me.
Oh, I did invite you.
I'll do my union.
Sorry to break it to you, bucko.
Bro, he's a party animal streamer.
That is... I'm sorry.
He's a party animal streamer.
Sorry that you have to do that.
He tells me to win if you get kicked off.
Wait.
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
Like...
Alright.
We're ready.
Alright, into the game.
Okay, I'll work on doing...
Wait, who's defending and who's...
I'm just gonna beat the shit out of them.
Okay, but are you defending beating the shit out of them or offense beating the shit out of them?
Offense.
Offense?
Okay, I'll go with short for it and then Bree and Ditto go defense.
Okay.
I'll focus on Arcane.
Alright, we got this.
Arcane?
League of Legends?
Oh, the misery.
Everybody wants to be my enemy.
Are we ready?
I don't know if I wrote ready yet.
Okay.
Apparently, they lost their last game too.
Whoever loses this one is the biggest loser.
Yeah.
Guys, I don't know if I can handle losing again.
Obviously.
What will happen if you lose short for it?
What will you do?
The night sky gets angry.
Even the devil shudders.
Guys, we don't want short for to lose again.
We don't know what he's gonna be like after.
Yes, because we're one to one.
Wait, that means there's a team that lost every game.
What?
That's not us, though, because we had our one.
We're ready.
Maybe it was the people that we went against the first time.
And maybe they were just not good at the game.
And we got false help.
Look.
This team is a bunch of TikTokers.
Actually, I don't know.
Yeah, I only know one TikToker.
We're just a bunch of YouTubers.
I'm not.
I'm normal.
Sure you are.
Ah, this one is so hard.
Yeah, your defense.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
We got this.
Alright, it's fine.
I will beat everyone up.
Wait, one of them is an actual Minecraft player on Joe's team?
What?
It's over.
They have a minecrafter.
My quest is to be one.
No.
Okay.
I'm going in.
We're blue.
Ow, you fucking punched me.
I thought you were going in the machine.
I'm trying.
No, I'm in it with him.
No, I got him down.
I thought you were going in ours.
Who's going in ours?
No, I'm doing offense with you.
Oh, okay.
And then I'm picking the arcade when I do.
We need people at our machine.
Alright.
I'm getting in.
You get involved.
Wait, we need to stop them though.
Oh my god.
Wait, who's getting in ours?
Who's supposed to be getting in ours?
I don't know, but I'm...
I think that was Doki.
No, I said I'm doing offense.
I'm doing offense and I'm doing theirs.
That's what I meant.
You got it.
No.
Okay, I'm going to need you to...
Wait, okay.
Oh my god.
Yeah, they did.
They did.
I'm trying to grab it so I can get on to the bomb.
Please.
I'm trying.
Got him.
I'm grabbing him.
I got him.
Wait, where am I?
Where am I?
What?
Oh my god, they knocked me out.
I punched him out.
We got a bunch.
Why would I grab the fucking stick?
I'm going.
They keep trying to fucking get to the bomb.
Who's in it?
Give me the bomb.
You go.
I'm trying.
I punched him.
I'm trying to grab.
You go.
Punch him out.
They got me out.
Okay.
I'm gone.
I'm on it.
Okay, we're all passed out.
Wait, you guys haven't grabbed anything.
We're trying.
Okay.
No.
They got him.
Oh shit.
I'm sorry.
That was my bad.
Oh god.
You got it.
Nice.
No.
I'm out.
Oh my god.
They're so good.
These are mines out there.
I got some points.
Nice.
I'm trying to grab.
Grab me the machine, not the stick.
Oh my god.
When you're on it, they can knock you out.
I noticed that.
You don't have a shield when you're on it.
Guys, I think it's over.
When you're on the enemies.
I think it's over.
I think it's over, guys.
I'm trying my best.
I knocked them out.
Grab the stick.
I'm trying.
I knocked out two.
No.
They got it.
We got it.
We're fine.
Okay.
I'm trying to knock them out.
Tripper, are you knocking them out?
Of course I am.
I got the bomb.
I spotted it with the bomb.
My points.
No.
They got it.
Cheeper.
It's okay.
We have the second round.
Guys, we have the second round.
Look, they have a minecrafter.
Yeah.
What's the second round?
The second round is...
It's beast hockey.
Oh, shit.
That has ice.
Lemonade my neck with dripping.
All I'm going to do is beat up the goalie.
That's all I'm going to do.
I'm just here to beat up the goalie.
That's supposed to be my...
That's supposed to be my strat.
Wait.
No, you don't.
You're the one to score.
Well, usually when I play these, I only try and grief the enemy team.
Okay.
But, like, are you good at scoring, though?
I don't know.
Wait.
I'm going to beat up the goalie.
And then I'm going to...
I'm going to steal the shield.
I'll try my best.
I'm going to steal this shield after.
Wait.
That's...
dank dank.
It's okay.
Doki, but you're Canadian.
Look, I have very limited knowledge on hockey.
Other than...
other than the Canucks team.
I played a lot of hockey when I was younger.
Wait.
Yeah.
You're Canadian, too, Surefour.
You should be the scorer.
I say you're...
I played right side defense when I played hockey.
Oh, yeah.
Today you're going to be offense today.
I'm offensive.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm going in.
I'm going in to steal it.
Wait.
I got it out.
I distracted the goalie.
Surefour, this is your time.
I stole it.
Surefour.
What the fuck do you want from me?
I literally saved us.
And then I got knocked out.
What am I supposed to do here?
All I'm saying is you had the Canadian buff.
Listen.
It's not just me.
Remember, 80%.
Who's our goalie?
It's not me.
I'm out.
I'm fucking stealing your shield.
Oh, no!
We have no goalie!
I'm my offense and I'm my goalie!
Look!
There's no one there!
The enemy team picked up our shield that they're supposed to use.
I said I was.
I wasn't goalie.
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Go, go, go!
I'm knocked out!
I'm knocked out.
I'm out.
I'm out cold.
I'm fucking dead.
Nice!
Nice.
Yes!
Yippee!
You idiot!
See, you say I'm offense but we got two on the offensive side so I have to play defense!
Wait, we can have two offense?
But then we have no defense!
Oh, wait, what about the other girls?
What are you trying to say about the other girls?
All I'm saying is I'm the flex right now.
Okay, look, I'm getting rid of the goalie right now.
Look, I'm getting rid of the goalie.
The goalie got rid of me though.
The goalie got rid of me.
I punched him.
Okay.
I'm trying to.
I'm just punching them all out.
They stole our shield.
I got the shield!
I'm coming back for you guys!
I got the shield for you too!
Uh oh.
Why are you stealing?
Ping def.
No!
I hit the shield.
Oh!
No!
We're out!
It's okay.
I'm getting my wood.
Oh my god!
Bro, this guy is a minecrafter right there.
I fucking dropped his shield.
No!
Oh!
What's going on?
They grabbed our shield.
They grabbed your shield?
I got it!
I got it back!
Oh my god!
Nice!
Grab the shield back!
It's okay!
Here, do you want me to defend?
You go.
I got the shield!
Nice!
They got the shield back.
I knocked that bit out.
Okay.
Yeah.
You can tell this guy is a party animal player.
Ow!
Oh!
I died!
I knocked him out!
Nice!
Oh my god!
I got the goalie!
And I got the shield!
Nice!
What is happening to this pup?
Okay.
Yeah, I knocked one out.
Oh fuck.
Oh my god.
Nice!
Okay!
Uuugh!
That's your part!
Oh!
I jumped!
No!
Yeah!
Guys, this is all looking so good.
No, no, no.
This is our comeback.
It's good.
It's our comeback.
It's the winnable.
Guys, we're losers too.
Okay, okay.
I'm coming in to actually help.
For real.
Oh, okay!
Hey, I'm for real this time!
For real, for real.
I'm actually here.
I shall assist.
Okay.
I shall use my Canadian debuff.
That's it, Jill Bart.
Knocked me out too many times.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I'm hanging over!
What do you want me to do?!
I'm literally here!
You hit me twice!
I set that up for you, man.
I set it up.
Yeah, and I knocked out two of them motherfuckers.
Okay, wait.
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for the pass.
Okay.
Oh, not that bit.
Yes.
Oh, no!
Oh, shit!
Oh, shit.
I almost knocked you out.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Nice!
It's a party animal.
No!
Guys, I got some bad news.
They only need one more.
Oh, guys, guys, surely, surely we can come back.
It's a comeback right here, right?
Surely.
Okay.
They're just getting hard bullied, though.
It's a comeback.
It's so wittable.
It's the comeback of the century.
This is it.
Oh, shit.
Our goalie's down.
Oh, no!
Okay.
Oh, I'm down!
This is just a round robin.
We're not last because we won our one game.
That's all that matters.
That's true.
We're not last.
Does that mean we progress or are we out?
No, this was a round robin, so then we have seeded after this.
Then it's like single elimination, I think.
It's single elimination after this.
Which is good!
We purposely lost so we can get easier games.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Doki, I have some bad news for you.
That's not how seeding works.
If you're last, that means you go against If you're last, that means you go against top seed, which means you go against the hardest opponent.
No, that's not how that works.
There's no way.
That's how that works, actually.
Where did you get those rules?
Who told you that?
It was your pro player.
Who told you?
You were a pro player.
I played professional video games.
You were a pro player, but times have changed.
Times have not changed.
Maybe in the VTuber world, but this is the Twitch Rivals.
Times have changed.
This is the Twitch Rivals.
It's not VTuber exclusive.
Okay, but like, why would they put us in the...
Why would they put us in the harder queues when we're losing?
Wake up to reality.
Nothing goes right in this accursed world.
No, but things are supposed to go right!
It's supposed to be our world!
Crying emoji.
Okay.
Alright, how is the seating?
Okay, second stage.
Single elimination.
Best of three games.
First to three points.
Oh, it's first to three points.
Oh, okay.
Uh...
Wait, but it doesn't even tell...
Oh, I think it's just...
Is it just beat-em-up or quarterfinals?
Conveyor trebuchet wind tunnel.
Oh no.
What's conveyor?
Con...
Oh god, wait, what is conveyor?
Shrug.
What is conveyor?
What is conveyor, guys?
What is this?
Oh, it's a big conveyor.
Yeah, but is it like PvP or...
Yeah, last stand is like PvP.
You have to dump people off.
Um...
There's a bunch of weapons that spawn in and then you pick them up and then you dump them off the side.
Oh, okay.
So, hopefully this should be good, cause it's just beating people up.
Yeah, yeah, hopefully that'll be easy, right?
Yeah.
I love beating people up.
See, that's good.
I'm buying earth runes right now.
Hopefully.
We got this.
You're min-mining again?
Yeah.
Okay, back to my dailies.
Back to your dailies?
Free, entertain us!
I'm playing Neopets!
Entertain us!
I got more core stuff to do!
People still play Neopets?
Yeah, they like recently uh, they recently sold Neopets to uh, some tech guy who is like a Neopets fan.
Yeah, who like is actually like doing stuff.
And then they're rebuilding Yeah, they're rebuilding the...
Uh, they're rebuilding the... Does it still look like it was made in 2001?
No, it's... Yes.
Oh, okay.
It looks like it was made in like 2012.
Huh.
They upgraded it a little bit.
Right.
I know like, I know they're trying to do like something, uh...
I know they're trying to do like some updates to it.
And adding new game modes.
Yeah.
No, they're doing a lot.
Like they're doing events and stuff finally.
And they brought back unconverted pets.
Which is amazing.
Oh yeah, I remember that.
Yeah.
I remember that.
Because they sent like a fucking newsletter out to everybody about it.
Yeah!
Yeah.
I'm autistic enough that I cried when they brought back, uh, unconverted pets.
Yeah, cause then you can like, you, people were like selling it for like crazy amount of real money.
It was like hundreds of dollars.
If you could get a Pokemon, or a Pokemon, a Neopet with like a good name, it was genuinely hundreds of dollars.
It was like, yeah.
And I remember like you can actually buy like real Neopoints and like real paintbrushes, like instead of real fucking money.
Yeah.
Wait, did you actually cry?
No, cause I'm autistic.
That wasn't a joke.
I was just, you know, you know.
My god, that was fairy sweet talk.
Little like seven year old Brute was really happy, okay?
I was living a really good life.
Yeah.
I miss Neopets.
I used to like, grind that game as if it was a fucking job.
Dude, same.
When I was like really young, cause like that was my life.
Oh yeah, when I was young too.
I did Neopet dailies.
Just like how people today do Genshin dailies.
And Honkai dailies.
I do Neopet dailies.
Yeah, no, I did that when I was a child.
Yeah, I stopped when I became an adult.
And there was like a website called Sunny Neo or something.
Sunny Neo!
And then they would have like a checklist of like, here's some stuff you have to do every day.
And then I would click every link every day to make sure I could get my dailies done.
Neopets was my gacha.
Yeah.
Yes, but it was free.
The only time I was spending was, the only thing I was spending was my time.
Time is money.
I was not spending actual money.
I didn't get scammed into doing the whole, what was it?
The Neopets exclusive shit.
Doki is just hurting my feelings right now.
Every single sentence.
Yeah, imagine spending money on Neopets.
I didn't spend real money on that.
Into the Neomall.
That's wild.
Imagine spending money on this game.
I know, right?
Imagine spending money on Neomall and Neopets Premium for the Super Wizard.
Just because you wanted to, like, search up the lowest prices.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
It's not worth your time.
I don't know what the hell is going on.
Doki is hurting my feelings and making fun of my spending choices.
That's what's happening.
That's sick.
Oh my god.
Look, I got priorities, okay?
My priorities are very stupid.
Oh my god.
You know, like, when we were fighting at Joe's team, a bunch of his... I don't know if it was happening in the chat, but a bunch of his chatters came to my chat just to, like, cheer for Joe.
Really?
That's funny.
What supportive guys.
And then when we lost, we were like, Yeah!
Joe's better!
And I was just like, what the fuck?
Happy little guys.
Got to tone down that happiness there to their own chat.
Chat hoppers.
Yeah.
Preview!
That's true.
It's not showing up with the map.
What?
What do you mean?
The new game.
It's not showing up.
Oh, the quarterfinals?
Oh shit!
The quarterfinals!
Who played against these people?
ZuriSparks.
No, they're all new people.
Nice.
Alright, if we lose this, we're out.
Just so you guys know.
It is life or death for real.
It don't feel so good.
It's life or death.
Right here.
Wait, it is not showing up.
Right now.
I thought you were lying.
Why would I be lying?
I thought you were lying about this.
Compulsive liar.
I know, because you lied about your resume.
I'm sorry.
You saw that first round.
I carried at least two things to the exit.
Did we see that second and third round?
I think that was...
I'm just being held back.
You're being held back?
Name names right now!
Who is it?
I don't really want to.
Not to cause any drama.
I'm just saying that I'm not being let...
Show my true skill in this game.
Alright.
Why is it not showing up?
I wanna join.
I wanna be part.
Still not created yet.
Oh.
We... Okay.
Team Squeaks and Team Joe are against each other.
So if we win this, we might have to go against Joe again.
Joe?
Joe Mama.
Okay.
That's weird.
I haven't seen it yet.
Alright.
Somebody send this guy a friend ID.
And I will invite you.
And then...
Free.
You...
You give your friend ID there.
And then invite us.
Okay.
Copy.
What's going on?
Oh.
Apparently the room is not showable.
So like they have to invite us individually with the friend ID.
What the?
So we just gotta wait.
How long?
We gotta wait.
The first one to die is dead weight.
Alright.
Everyone make sure Doki dies.
What?
I'm the captain.
I can't be dead weight.
Captains are usually the dead weight.
I literally scored.
I was the only person that scored.
Captains are usually supposed to be the charismatic person to bring people together.
Not to actually do anything.
It's like a CEO.
Okay.
But I actually did stuff.
Keep telling yourself that.
Oh yeah.
The first game.
I scored almost all the goals in the first game.
Who set up those scores?
The second game.
I scored the only goal in the second game.
That was luck.
I also kicked it forward.
I knocked two people out.
Oh yeah.
Game three.
I set up the goal for you.
I knocked two people out before you set it up.
See, this is the self-centered thinking we're talking about here.
This is team games, but you're only thinking about what you did.
Yeah, but you're self-centered as well because you were telling people that you did all that stuff as well.
You told Gus that you were 80% of the team I'm just saying my piece of the story.
My story matters.
What is the friend ID?
It's in your fucking profile.
In Party Atlas.
Are they just waiting for us?
Where are you?
Where is this room?
So am I.
What do they want?
Calm down.
Try again.
Oh god.
I've been searching up for too long.
You told me to calm down.
What the?
Do I just like add someone to wait to get invited?
Yeah, we have to wait for Bree to get in and then she's gonna invite us in a vision.
She's gonna invite me and then I'll invite you too.
Okay.
Okay, accept.
Whoa.
Okay.
Invite a friend.
Oh, wait.
Do I have to add you guys?
Oh, no.
Guys.
Just add me.
There.
Did you add me?
I did it on Party Animals.
I did it.
Yo, one new game friend?
I have friends.
Thank you.
Yay!
Okay, Trevor got in as well.
Alright, nice.
I'm here to slay.
Yeah, the last is the beat up.
Oh, okay.
How come we couldn't find this lobby?
Like, what the fuck?
I don't know.
Oh, it's because you didn't put the space dash.
Oh!
I just put the jar and I couldn't find it.
I nearly copied and pasted this.
So that's on there.
Well, yeah, because in the copy-paste, there's no space bar.
Oh.
Okay, so all we do is beat them up and then throw them out.
Are you guys going to throw things?
Yeah, I'm going on the sauce.
Alright.
Whoever dies first is a dead weight.
I'm knocking Doki Bird out.
What?
How could you do this to the captain?
How could you do this?
I can't believe you've done this.
I can't believe it.
We're a team.
I got a bomb.
That's not good.
Oh my god.
I didn't get anybody.
Get up!
Wait, how do I get up?
Wait, how do I...
Oh, it's so hard when you're on the side.
I don't know how to get up.
Okay, it's up to you guys.
I'm out.
Oh, my Doki!
Wait, were you the first one out?
No, Ditto was.
Ditto was.
Me.
No!
I got my one.
I thought Ditto would fucking walk off the conveyor.
Okay, I'm alive.
I'm alive.
No!
How did that happen?
Okay, wait.
I'm throwing bombs.
I'm throwing bombs for you guys.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, never mind.
I'm...
I might be dead.
No, no, no.
This is the end.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm okay.
You're okay.
I'm dead.
Free, this is it.
This is on you.
This is...
This is all on you.
Okay, goodbye.
Goodbye.
I threw a banana.
That was their one.
Ditto is not okay.
I'm in time.
I missed.
Oh, free!
Free!
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
No!
Uh-oh.
Save me.
No shot!
What happened?
What happened from far?
I thought this was your game!
Honestly, this is pinged.
Yeah, this is pinged.
Oh, I fell!
Guys.
Alright guys, it's up to you.
Good luck.
Guys.
When I heard I fell off and I'm the only one here now, I'm scared.
No, you got Ditto.
Ditto's there.
Oh my gosh!
Ditto, are you still alive?
Yeah.
I don't know how to jump off this one.
What do you mean?
Oh, not that way!
Now you're the only one.
Okay, now I'm still here.
What?
What do you mean?
Now you're the only one.
They're all coming after me!
Hey, freaking kill them.
I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
Bumba.
No.
You just got put in the fucking montage.
Oh my gosh.
Alright, this is the comeback.
I got knocked out instantly.
I don't know, guys.
Okay, you just pushed me!
Sorry.
I would take one guy with me.
You took one guy with you?
Hell yeah!
Guys, I can't get back up.
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna try and kill him and then I'm gonna take him down with me as well.
Yeah.
That's my plan now.
No!
Oh my god!
He's growing!
He has the spinach!
Okay.
He has the spinach.
I'm a little scared.
Okay.
Ow!
Jump!
Oh no!
Help me!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
My hero academia.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Back
up!
Oh, there you go.
Guys, I'm struggling!
If you jump kick, I think it's more of a chance to get up.
Oh, really?
Okay.
That's good to know.
No!
Oh, I died.
Oh no.
Oh, now there's three.
Oh god.
I'm in.
Nice, Doki.
Not nice anymore.
Not nice anymore!
How does that one hit not hit him off?
No!
It's up to Ditto!
Wait, no.
Ditto's dead.
Okay.
Nice.
Hey guys, I think...
Look, I got my one.
I got my...
Guys, I got my one.
What were you guys doing?
Who got their ones?
Uh, I got my five.
You did not get five.
Only two people fucking died in that entire time.
Yeah, I got five.
You didn't get five.
You missed my clutch guardian angel save.
No, that was amazing.
Yeah, but you guys died regardless so does it matter?
Listen, what's more important in life, saving someone or killing someone?
That's what I thought.
Well, if that person you're killing is gonna end up fucking like going to jail anyway for committing murder, then like killing them is a better deal.
You heard it here.
Doki thinks murder is justifiable.
Yeah, if you're murdering another murderer.
If you guys stop and cry, if that person is gonna commit multiple murders and you murder them before they commit multiple murders, then it's justifiable.
It's like traveling back in time.
What if that person was about to murder someone who murdered their child?
Well, what if that child grows up to commit more murders and he was like a time traveler?
Yeah, I think that sounds logic.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Alright, you heard it here.
Doki said it's fine to murder children so they don't become mules.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm saying that child We should kill all the children before they do anything.
Therefore, there will be no problems.
I'm saying that murderer was a time traveler who knows the future of what that child's gonna do.
It's like if you have the power to time travel, we travel back in time.
You know how your logic is flawed?
How?
Because if there's time travel, it would already happen by now.
Yeah, because it's a paradox.
What if they created a multiverse so that it drifts off to a separate multiverse?
Multiverse!
I love Marvel!
Yo, someone pull the trigger.
I'm going in deep.
Go, go in.
Go with the bomb.
Oh, no, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Go in!
Yeah.
Get the easy!
Okay, then we have to...
Oh, they're here!
They're here!
That fucking bomb!
We gotta take them out!
No!
Hey, they're chucking!
Oh, no!
What happened?
All of our stuff got destroyed.
No!
We gotta make sure we got... I'm bringing the bombs over!
I'll be smacking them.
Just keep putting bombs in.
Yeah.
Get the bombs!
Oh my god!
Throw them off!
No!
Get over here.
I made one bomb go off.
Drag him down!
Drag him down with me!
Whoa!
You're gonna die with me!
You're gonna die with me if it's the last thing I do!
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
I spawned back into my own base.
Get the bomb!
Go do it!
Yeah!
I'm back.
I'm bringing the bomb over.
Oh, sweet.
Sweet, sweet, sweet.
That's me.
Take him over!
No!
Oh, no.
Whatever.
It's fine.
He's over.
I got crushed.
Put the bombs in!
We can!
I'm coming!
Oh, they sent two people over.
It's okay.
I'm back.
Okay, do the lever!
Do the lever!
Quickly!
I'm trying!
Ow!
That's me, Ditto!
That's me!
Ditto!
Okay.
Hey, we're not doing too good.
I got the bomb over!
Take the bomb and do it!
Come in!
Oh,
he caught me with the bomb!
What
did you guys do?
Uh, the bombs went off.
Guys, are we?
I think we're out.
I think we're out, guys.
Guys, we're not last.
We got one win.
No!
I can't feed my kid!
Poki's gonna kill my child!
Your future child.
Look, we're not last because we won one game.
Yeah, we got that very first game and then we got high egos and then we failed miserably the rest of the time.
I'm working!
We did the best we could.
For every winner, there has to be a loser.
Wait, starting map three?
Oh, wait.
One to one.
Yes.
Poki!
Question mark?
These guys on the enemy team don't know what the fuck's going on.
I'm like Rumpelstiltskin.
Oh my god!
It's okay.
It's all about the friends we made along the way.
Yeah, oh my god.
Yeah.
I'm so excited now in the future if someone asks me to play, I could just say oh yeah, no, we won some games on Twitch Rivals and I can lie even more about my resume.
I'm so excited.
I got to play with the legendary Pussy Slayer.
Yeah.
I got my Warp Scepter during all this.
That's a dub.
It's okay.
In the end, everybody gets money.
Everybody gets money and that's what it's all about.
That's right!
Everybody wins something.
That's all that matters.
Exactly, guys.
GG is everybody.
What a journey.
Okay, GG.
There's been a team that lost every game and that's not our team.
Yeah, but they still were in the quarterfinals.
That's not our team.
There was a team that lost every game.
But that wasn't us.
Okay, that's all that matters.
That's all that matters.
GG is everybody.
GG.
Good luck with the rest of your day, guys.
See you next time.
Bye-bye.
Alright.
I had a great time.
I had a fun time with everyone.
It was honestly a huge blast playing with this team.
And we had a fun time with this team as well.
There's been some...
I feel like on Twitch, things just get much more cursed in general.
It's just the Twitch life.
.
Anyway, guys.
It's okay.
We won our first game.
That's all that matters.
It's all about the adventures and the fun we had.
.
Hey, guys.
We do have another stream tonight, everybody.
Look, I was not the dead weight.
I did some clutch shit.
That's all I'm saying.
.
I pulled off my ones.
I did my ones.
I defended so well during the trebuchet moment.
.
I fucking defended it so hard during the trebuchet and sent bombs over and everything.
Like, bro, come on.
.
I went full...
I fucking beat up the goalie and I scored like four goals.
.
All you did is punch the goal.
And I did my one.
I did my one.
Okay?
And I sent the bombs over.
What they did with the bombs was their job.
Like, I said I sent the bombs over.
They had to finish the job.
.
I did my 50% of the work.
I was sending bombs out.
I did... Okay.
That is not true.
At best, I was the 80% at that point.
.
I was the defender.
I was fucking sending bombs over.
I was carrying the bombs over and then I sent it over and then I... and then Bree had to do the defense for the other bombs.
Mr. Lane Robbins was the carry.
What is this?
You're supposed to be my echo chamber.
What the fuck is this?
Anyway, guys.
I had a great time with everybody.
.
I had a great time with my team.
For those who are new here.
Also, thank you for the .
I'm just about to end today because we just finished Twitch Rivals.
Anyway, guys.
If you're new here, I usually stream on the YouTube.
So, please check me out.
Doki Bird YouTube.
That's where I usually stream.
I actually have a stream tonight.
I'll be speaking Chinese tonight on YouTube with Hiro.
She's fluent and I'm not.
.
She actually knows how to read and write.
I don't know either.
Anyway, if you want to support me via other means, please check out my merch.
And if you want to know when I stream on Twitch, I usually tweet out when I'm streaming on Twitch on Twitter.
So, please follow me on Twitter.
What else?
Also, Friday.
There's going to be a slight change in the schedule on Friday.
I will be playing Marvel Rivals because I actually got invited to the Alpha test.
I knew tweeting that out was a good idea.
But, yeah.
A person who knows the community manager reached out to me and said that they wanted to send me a code to try out Marvel Rivals on Friday.
And they were possibly... I might be like...
I don't know what it's called.
Let me read what they said.
They want to make me one of the official content creators for Marvel Rivals.
I'm not sure yet.
But maybe I'll find out later today because they said they want to give me more details about it.
But, yeah.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Pause, check up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And when you stay up from me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.